what prompted you to shoot the first
series of the iPhone it was I had shot
three short films before this and it was
all with like nice good you know
professional-grade cameras but when it
came to this I it had been sometime in
between that so I didn't have the
resources at the time and I knew I have
a video production degree a background
in that I knew that I could probably
push the technology so I saw somebody
else do it and I was like you know what
I could I could do that and so I decided
to get the iPhone and I bought but I
knew that it wasn't just gonna be the
iPhone it had to be something where I
could actually have a lens on it and
that's when I decided to get the owling
which is uh this this nice little piece
of aluminum it's like a pound of
aluminum and then it has a wide-angle
lens on it and you just get the phone at
the time I had an iPhone for now if an
iPhone 4s better picture quality you
just kind of just pop it into this I
don't know if you can see it on the
camera but and where did you purchase at
the time it was Ali booboo calm but they
got bought out
it's a ALM now some like them so yeah
it's like legit I use it yeah it has all
the regular tripod holes and all the you
can attach you know the mic has a boot
right here and then you know yeah it's
so I I figured at the time it would I
knew I could make it and at the
beginning I didn't want to market it as
an iPhone web series I wanted to try and
pass it off as like it just like I
didn't want people to think about it
being an iPhone series you know thank
you and it's just now that we're getting
into season 2 that I'm sort of like yeah
I did it on the iPhone
I'll let the cat out of the bag kind of
thing yeah I felt that that was actually
a huge selling point because that in
hindsight yeah well and it still paid
off because a lot of people ended up you
know when people see it they're like oh
it's cute it's a nice story and all it
looks good you shot with a holy
how'd you do that and it's like I mean
all of a sudden like respect just
escalates infinitely and people are like
really then all of a sudden interests is
just tenfold and they're like they don't
like tell us how you did this isn't
phenomenal and it obviously it's Chad
and his editing his vision and
everything and that probably is just
amazing like what that little lens did
and takes already great camera and a
phone just exploded in some that you
would never know yes and I know I
thought I show my friends when it was
first time and I was like look at this
and then afterwards I say we shut that
on my phone and they all freaked out so
I mean it's a great selling point you
know yeah so I mean our did you think
that during the filming though you know
like as an actor you know you want that
big camera do what you wanted to be
prestigious and we was going through
your money out of the face I I kind of
just no actually I remember I like to
think I like to think that I wasn't
negative about it I don't believe I was
I I didn't honestly I don't think I
really thought about it much I just
would see the footage that he did I
think we did a couple test shots and I
was a little skeptical at first I was
like okay I found this and let's see how
this works out then I saw the rig and I
was like that's kind of cool but let me
see how it looks and then he shot some
tests like this test episode cut it
together yeah and that pretty much that
just nailed that I was like I'm fine
with this and it makes sense because
it's quick it's easy it's affordable it
looks so much better than what you'd
think it would I'm down and I'm you know
I'm from the I love the streets of a
girl of filmmaking I mean that's you
know I used to do that in Maryland and I
just that's I I like that and I respect
it
more than I'm not saying I don't like
big big big productions but when it's
like you know us I respect the hustle
and the passion
to go into a project to get it off the
ground and finish it when you have
nothing with you so that is yeah this is
just a sort of a flagship production for
that sort of ideal and belief system
I think web series is perfect to try
this out mmm to go forward and just
shoot the entire production on an iPhone
it's such a kind of wild wild west kind
of medium right now
you